[Music]
it's almost perfect almost yes give it
give it some more balls there's some
rock and roll hyah
can you go a bit higher if I go any
higher any dogs will hear me
[Applause]
are we done I want you to stamp to this
beat genius thank you come on imagine
thousands of people doing this stamp to
this beat come on now I want you to clap
on the third beat what's going on you
know if you're on time I want to give
the audience a song that they can
perform so what can I do imagine
thousands of people doing this
what's the lyric
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
- please wasn't ready terrific he's
fantastic he was better than that he's a
bloody phenomenon
never seen anyone interact with a crowd
like that got that John things rockem's
creeping back in I know what you mean
that's important
stay here and I know be alright that's
David you ready
you're burning I can live both hands
ready the girl is so divine just need a
better time
Annie thanks for the support
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think Karpin leaves at my
hand on with a drill and a file right
he's a rollers I should priceless by
doing all that that's right
[Music]
you